wait a second
so 54 years later after the
assassination of President John F
Kennedy they're still not releasing all
the files do you not be misled by this
word addresses nobody is or was asking
for any addresses all you have to do is
look at the details which is that the
FBI the CIA and other unnamed agencies
let me guess the NSA deemed that this
information was sensitive to national
security so the question becomes who on
earth are they protecting whose identity
nevermind the addresses fifty four years
later do you want to know whose name is
in there I guarantee it George HW Bush
that's right former president and former
CIA director who's already been linked
years ago through a Declassified
document that shows that he was involved
in the investigation of JFK which of
course he denied and said that it must
be a different George Bush and years
later when questioned about it again he
refused to comment on it entirely and
although George HW Bush would become the
director of the CIA 13 years after the
death of JFK at the time of JFK's death
he was indeed a top-level CIA agent in
fact even briefing President Dwight
Eisenhower who of course was the
president before JFK so you need take
into account that he's already been
linked to the investigation that he was
a top official which obviously anyone
investigating the death or homicide the
assassination of a sitting president
would be assigned to top-level officials
which he was he denied it and here we
are fifty-four years later and the CIA
the FBI and other agencies consider it
critical to national security this in
itself is a complete admission of a
cover-up
think about it someone who was a
president and the director of the CIA
would have incredible knowledge and
information that the general public
would not have and for some reason they
still don't want the general public to
have all the information if you're not
aware George HW Bush south is rapidly
deteriorating if you haven't heard there
are rumors going around that his mind is
going that he has become senile he's
saying weird things and he's not
completely coherent so considering the
that he was the director of the CIA just
imagine what he knows even more things
than President Snow and he's going
senile isn't it possible that they're
afraid he might say something I mean
just look at the unusual coincidence of
the timing of the fact that they were
gonna withhold these names and addresses
to the precise timing of these groping
and sexual misconduct allegations made
against them is it possible that the
powers that be one of burden and stress
the mind of an old man in order to
prevent him from saying something
related to the JFK incident or maybe
it's a threat maybe they're afraid he
might say something on his deathbed
knowing that he is rapidly deteriorating
now obviously that's just conjecture and
speculation on my behalf but the powers
that be have been indeed protecting the
Bush family for far longer than most
people are aware of take Prescott Bush
the father of George HW Bush and the
grandfather of George W and Jeb which
many people are not aware was a founding
director of the Union Banking
Corporation which literally funded the
United States and the Nazis during World
War two literally funding both sides
which has to be the most sinister thing
possible so that way you win and make a
fortune no matter who loses and despite
this being in violation of trading with
the enemy act absolutely nothing
happened to him in less than 10 years
later he would become a United States
Senator but do not be fooled by these
headlines that say he assisted Hitler's
rise to power and make you think that
all maybe these gave him money and
loaned him money in the 30s before World
War two no no they were doing business
in funding the Nazis into October of
1942 three years after Hitler invaded
Poland and started World War two and he
got off the hook completely gave birth
to a child who become CIA director a
president who will give birth to a child
who'd become president whose other son
was trying Lee the powers that be were
trying to force him into the White House
despite overwhelming public dissent and
having no interest in Jeb Bush becoming
the president we all saw what happened
there now if you're wondering what this
has to do with the JFK's death I'm
priming your brain for the information
that you're about to get never mind all
the conspiracy theories as they've been
called involving the grassy knoll the
fence the storm drain and various
theories on who a second gunman could
I've been because all those things are
debatable look at the evidence that we
do know which is positive that there was
a cover-up take for example the
so-called stretcher bullet that was
found on the gurney of governor Connally
which of course was injured in the
assassination events of JFK this bullet
went through two people a neck and two
bones and somehow is miraculously
untouched and when you compare the same
bullet to other bullets found in this
event you can see the dramatic
difference and if you're not familiar
with ballistics well bullets are made of
lead which is very malleable and even
when you shoot them into water look at
the incredible damage and they want us
to believe that somehow this bullet was
found on a stretcher with zero damage
and zero blood on it at all in other
words somebody planted it who had access
to that hospital and we know now that
George HW Bush was involved in this
investigation and denied it a top-level
CIA agent so this is the part where a
lot of people even though approximately
7 out of 10 Americans is convinced of a
cover-up in a second gunman many other
people don't buy into it because they're
like what why would the government kill
their own president they just don't
think it's possible so let me get into
that and start off by showing you with
Dwight Eisenhower the president right
before JFK his very last speech before
leaving the White House was literally
about outing the military-industrial
complex that various powers that are
able to remain anonymous in the
intelligence community were able to
seize power that far exceeded the
Constitution and the powers of the
presidency that was his very last speech
before leaving the White House yet most
people are completely unaware the JFK
made a speech just three months into his
presidency just three months not even
after Dwight Eisenhower's speech and in
the speech he discussed his secret
societies in the very grave danger and
ambitions for those who want increased
security and this ties right into the
reason or a motive a significant motive
of why the powers that be and the
intelligence communities or the
military-industrial complex would want
to kill JFK take for example the Cuban
Missile Crisis all the intelligence
officials and chief of staff's wanted to
launch and go straight to war with Cuba
JFK did not go along with it showed
restraint and he made the right decision
and this is the part where it gets
really
disturbing declassified documents that
most people are completely unaware of
prove that the United States government
conspired to commit a false flag attack
to blame on Cuba in order to implement a
full-fledged invasion of the country
they even discussed blowing up a drone
airliner and faking it to look like the
Cubans and shot it down
they discussed blowing up a warship
inside Guantanamo Bay they discuss
lobbing mortars in to Guantanamo Bay's
base itself and blaming it all on the
Cubans and they even outline how they
could utilize the casualty lists in
newspapers to grow indignation from the
American public to support this war and
you can press pause and look at all the
other tactics that they were
investigating this is real and just look
at the date on that less than a year
after JFK said it would happen so here's
the part you really need to know
JFK signature was the only one left that
was required in order to implement this
plan he refused so the second most
likely reason involves Vietnam although
JFK did send troops and at the time of
his death there was approximately 16,000
he refused to do a full-fledged invasion
like the powers-that-be wanted to and
you can see here
JFK died towards the end of 1963 and
just over a year later that number would
grow exponentially and even more in the
years following but what 99% of
Americans I would venture to say have no
idea is that it has been proven through
declassified documents verified by
report from the NSA that the Gulf of
Tonkin incident which involved an attack
on US warships from the North Vietnamese
was completely a staged false flag event
that did not happen and they utilized it
as an excuse for Congress to vote for
war on the resolution to completely
invade that country and that happened in
August of 1964 less than 11 months after
the assassination of JFK the president
who refused to fully invade Vietnam this
is real this is verifiable yes the
United States government's excuse for
invading Vietnam was made up and all the
documents prove this in 99 percent of
the public has no idea and it gets even
worse did you know that Richard Nixon
it's been proven decades later in a low
LBJ thought this the entire time in the
American public was completely unaware
that Richard Nixon and his quest to
become president literally spent money
and bribed various Vietnamese officials
in order to postpone the Paris peace
talks which would of course end the
conflict or war I should say in Vietnam
all you ever hear about is Richard Nixon
being tricky dick and Watergate bugging
the hotel rooms of his political
opponents to get himself an advantage
when all this time it was known that he
literally sabotage the Paris peace talks
in order so he could get credit when he
became president for ending the war and
being like look I'm the hero meanwhile
more than 20,000 people were killed and
who knows how many injured while those
peace talks were delayed just like I
mentioned in the video prior to this one
where I say that the mainstream media is
complicit and cover-ups in manipulation
of information just look at the date
that the New York Times covered this
story New Year's Eve probably the least
watched news day of the year and people
are only the only thing they're watching
is Times Square and the ball dropping do
you see what I'm talking about here the
cover-up is real the United States
government plotted a false flag attack
to go to Cuba unsuccessful because JFK
said no JFK said no to a full-scale
invasion less than a year later they
literally voted to go invade Vietnam
based on a false flag attack that never
happened and they knew it and this is a
hundred percent verifiable declassified
documents prove this 99% again like I
say probably maybe ninety eight have no
idea the truth is stranger than fiction
guys I'm not kidding when I say that
this is real so when you consider that
someone or multiple people are still
alive to have some sort of information
that's critical to national security is
still being withheld fifty four freaking
years after the assassination of JFK
what does that tell you when you look at
the incredible coincidence of timing
involving the George HW Bush groping
allegations to this when you consider
the fact that he is obviously a person
of incredible knowledge and information
that the general public does not have
just from being a CIA agent and
president and that his mind is going and
you start connecting the dots and all
these possibilities it becomes
abundantly clear that this guy is
somebody that knows far more about the
death of JFK than the Amir
in public so why on earth is this a
national security issue well let's see
if the American public found out that a
former president and CIA director was
involved somehow in some way in the
death or cover-up of JFK there's your
national security concern because we
already know that the various powers
that be have been protecting this family
far longer than most people watching
this have even been alive guys the truth
is stranger than fiction if you support
my ambitions to expose truth like
subscribe and leave a comment all those
things will boost the algorithms on this
video and I also have a patreon account
help support me in my quest to expose
the truth and awaken the masses and
whatever the best ways that I can but
I'll wrap up there I'm Jimmy
this is bright insight take care
everybody